ce n'est un secret pour personne les
médias d'information traverse une crise
depuis plusieurs années avec des revenus
qui sont en chute libre et des mises à
pied très importante dans le domaine du
journalisme mais frédéric pour certains
médias comme par exemple le new york
times la situation est plutôt en congrès
à quoi encourageante c'est surprenant
quand même oui céline ça va plutôt bien
fait pour le quotidien de la grosse
pomme écouter une salle évidemment
d'information mythique et des chiffres
qui a été rendu public aujourd'hui
et regardez le nombre d'abonnements
maintenant on dépasse le 4 millions de
personnes dont qui défraye de l'argent
pour pouvoir s'abonner au new york times
et à leurs produits est plus
encourageant dans le fond c'est par le
web que ça se passe donc plus de trois
millions de personnes sont abonnées pour
les produits du new york times et ça
notamment pour des choses grâce à ça a
doublé en fait depuis 2010 est donc
c'est assez majeurs ils s'abonnent
pourquoi pour les mots croisés
évidemment pour aussi les applications
de restauration mais surtout et c'est là
plus encourageants trois quarts des gens
s'abonnent évidemment pour les nouvelles
les gens veulent s'informer alors
résultat bien plus de fréquentation du
site web tout ça aussi en partie grâce à
cet homme évidemment donald trump qui
n'arrêtent pas d'ailleurs de répéter que
ça va très mal au new york times met pas
du tout en fait regarder en 2018 ya eu
127 millions de profits pour le trot
l'entreprise donc c'est assez sain quand
même l'objectif maintenant pour le
quotidien c'est d'atteindre le 10
millions d'abonnés d'ici 2025 et aussi
ben écoutez ça va bien aussi pour le
journalisme puisque on engager plus de
120 journalistes l'année passée donc la
preuve qu'il ya vraiment un besoin
essentiel d'informer un mot sur le
washington post l'autre entreprise
américaine qui fonctionne très bien
propriété de jeff bezos vous savez c'est
l'homme le plus riche de la planète plus
de 130 milliards de dollars de fortune
personnelle et bien washington post là
aussi on a vu une fréquentation qui a
doublé donc on a deux fois plus
d'abonnés
ça va très bien grâce au web et on a
maintenant un peu plus de 800
journalistes qui travaillent là c'est
vraiment le web encore une fois qu'ils
génèrent tous ses profits pour ces
entreprises
et là aussi depuis 2010 7 mai 2010 c'est
très intéressant
par contre la même formule de succès
grâce à internet fonctionne beaucoup
moins bien pour d'autres médias qui ont
eu tout misé justement sur internet
effectivement égale acquis quelques
années on lançait des entreprises de
presse pour atteindre les gens un peu
plus jeunes c'est le cas par exemple de
buzzfeed mais regardez on venait
d'annoncer une mise à pied importantes
15% du personnel donc ses 220 personnes
qui se retrouvent sur le plancher vice
également vice nous très important mais
médias aussi au québec qu'au canada - 10
% à 250 personnes et plus on a aussi le
racing post
yahoo news ou encore et ol propriété de
la compagnie
verizon la c8 100 personnes qui se
retrouvent sur le pav évidemment c'est
très difficile et la raison mais c'est
en partie à cause de facebook parce que
facebook a changé son fameuse et
algorithmes qui permettait d'avoir sur
votre fil de presse ce genre d'articles
produits par ces entreprises là
malheureusement ils ont changé tout est
donc la fréquentation des sites de ces
entreprises ont commencé à chuter
il ya eu certains mêmes qui ont
complètement disparu de la circulation
évidemment d'ici deux ans qu'est ce qui
va se passer on n'en sait pas l'avenir
il n'y a pas de formule magique
malheureusement non mais tout le monde
cherche et où on cherche